Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier. It is...
LOUD IN HERE!
we! are! back! in! night! mare! mode!!!
I Haven't beaten you 'cause I haven't gotten to you. I've beaten you, beaten you, so there's no excuses about it
It's time to go
All I gotta do is beat these night five mo- sorry, these night five modes
And I'll be good to go. I still think they're gonna fuck with me one day and there's gonna be something here
but oh, well there's nothing now. So this is Five nights at Freddy's one,
Five nights at Freddy's one. That means that it's probably gonna be dickishly, but I think it's fine.
Like, I don't know how it could be bad unless there's something new about it that is bad!
So let's try it all I got(s) to do is not die. Oh fuck! Hey get the fuck outta here. What are you doing?
Oh shit- shut up
What? "static followed by scary demon noises"? Well, that's a little weird. You're already walking
so all I gotta do is just check the doors and check the light. You're already coming out.
God damn it. Ah Fu-
lights- oh what the- Whoa! Whoa! Wow! Wow! What the fuck? Whoa. Whoa, what the fuck was that about? Holy shit
o-oh god. Wait. What the fuck?
God damnit, ah man the-these fingies. They're not being very fingy. I'm checking these too much
I know but uh trying to be real gentle about it, I think
AH WHAAY- STOP DOING THAT,
NONSENSE!!!
Coming down, that's good.
Can you be done now? Can you be done with your tantrum?
Oh, guh, STOP!!
WHY?
What the fuck? I mean besides that- if that happens at the wrong time and Foxy's come and running down that the corrido-
Oh shit, whoose
Thought I heard someone, I... do hear someone, I think. This is fine...
This is fine! Whoa! Oh, god, fuck, every fucking time that- Oh hi. Okay, you're there
Are you gonna stop there or what? are you going right by? Okay, you're fine. You're fine.
I just gotta check you because if you pop up,
it's gonna be real- Oh, fuck. Oh you're closing that one. You're still there
Yeah, I think what I gotta do is I gotta wait for him to come out. Whoa shit. Okay double... double teaming. Oh
Oh fuck, no, not now! hey! Hey! HEY. HEY!
Hey, whoa. Hey, okay, is there someone there or is there someone not? Stop. Holy shit. Um, you're not there anymore
What the fuck! Are you there? Oh, you're not- AH!!
FUCK!
I am gonna die cuz I'm gonna run out power. What is that about?
Are you still there?
AH! WHAT THE FUCK?!
What is that about?!
Are you still there? Oh God, go away. Um.. Fuck. I'm gonna run out of power. Holy shit. This is tough
But not that tough
All I gotta get, is solid steel balls, and stop the goddamn not- miss- OHH!
Okay, that I didn't like. You still fucking-- oh my-! WHY??
WHY ARE YOU STILL THERE?
You still there?
No, okay. You haven't gone yet. You're still there for some fucking reason. I don't know why
Oh my god. Okay. I'm gonna run out of power because I gotta keep this door down for some fucking reason.
oh my god! OH MY GOD.
Don't you dum de dum me. I don't want to be dum de dummed. I'm nowhere near, I'm nowhere near time.
I am nowhere near time and I am out of power. I guess I'm near time. Alright, well, fuck it.
Okay, but I had another hour to go. Okay, it's fine. Kill me do it.
Oh, holy shit!
That's awful. I hate that. here we go. Come on. I'm ready for you. Take some of these!
[Jumpscare Warning]
[screams]
Okay?...
[Sad right door noises]
Don't- Don't you-
Don't you fucking do it. Alright, so I'm gonna take it j-just a step back just to breathe!
Oh, Fucking...let me BREATHE. Okay.
Alright.
So I'm guessing that with that game mode the right doors- at a certain point it's gonna stay closed
So my only objective is to not close it until as late as possible. Cuz if that fuckers just gonna stay there
I'm not gonna waste power trying to like...check to make sure he's still there.
He apparently is just gonna stay there.
So once he's there. He's there for good.
Do you understand what I'm talking about here? Do you get what I'm saying?
Once he's there. He's there for good. Why is my hand over there? It's over here.
I was being sassy on the hip but you get what I'm saying, right? Okay, let's do this again
All this is, is trial and error. I don't think it's that bad. I got to 5 a.m
Which is pretty far and that was with spastically waving my hands about- Shut up. Don't need that
You don't scare me no mo(re), because I've got the recipe for victory.
My hands are being a little- I don't know why but in here, the hands are just being a little bit caddywhompus
Ooh! Riiight. No it's fine- it's fine.
That ain't nothing. Turn that off, get that off. These ain't nothing.
I don't need to check the lights nearly as much as I'm checking!
Easy, easy. Like a dweam, like a dweam, like a dweam, like a dweam!
There he goes! Check that, get him to go down there, perfect.
Uh-huh, uh-huh. Uh-huh. Okay. Okay, you're walking. That's good.
You gonna keep walking or are you gonna stop there?
You're gonna keep walkin', good.
Stop. Stop- god fucking damn it
poop
Okay, none of that...none of that
Okay, you're there, but you're not in the doorway yet so I can squeeze- god fucking damnit. Okay. All right. Well, that's interesting
You're not in the doorway yet. So as soon as you're in the door, you're- yeah, you're staying right by
so I just got to watch for you.
Once you go, this is how we're gonna do this. Okay. There we go. That's good
Okay, you've- moved? Yep, there you are. Okay so that door is just no go for....ever! I guess
I'm just guessing that's what it is, right?
That's just what it is, getting a little spastic
but it's okay cuz he didn't go away at all! And I mean at all- oh shit, okay, that was very close
That was way too close, okay...
God dammit, that's a lot of power. I'm just watching this one from now on. I just watch this one.
When you move, okay, there you are, and I close that, and yeah, it's a lot of power, but with him not
Yeah, he's there, so he stays there. It's just- that's just the way it is.
No! 4am, 22 percent. ahh, umm, this is iffy...
You still there? Oh no, you're not, okay.
It's real iffy, I'm not a hundred percent sure about this one, but you know, it is what it is. Gotta be as
conserving of energy as I possibly can be. [music plays] none of that!
None of that. Okay. He's just coming down, not yet.
Close- about to run out of power
It's gonna be tight. It's gonna be real close!
[Jumpscare Warning]
Fucking god damn it!
Really?! Right then?! I could have made it!! Oh, fuck you! Fuck you, you piece of shit.
Ahhh, Fuck.
Gonna be like that? You're gonna be like that? Huh? You gonna be like THAT? You're gonna be like THAT? you're gonna be like
THAT?
That was close, that-that might have actually got it, to be honest. That might have actually got it
I don't need to check the lights
NEARLY as much as I'm checking them.
Every time I check a light is- whoa what the fuck? Wait, what the fuck?
Wait what the-?
Uhhhh, problem?
My buttons, uh
My buttons haven't-
HELLO?!
Hello?? My buttons! Um, okay
Well, loosen up my buttons ba... somebody fix my bu- whoa, okay
Alright. Well, you know, this will be the first buttonless run.
Alright. Well, no buttons for me! Cameras are for nerds.
I just gotta get Foxy reaction times, but that's about it.
No buttons, alright. We don't need buttons here. Buttons are for nerds
Do I see him walking?
No, god damn it! My fingers are so sticky in this- level! WHY. Fingies, behave yourselves
Okay, you're coming down that way. Okay, so I got people on both sides. Stop. No, not today. So far so good!
Weirdly enough. Okay, you go by there.
That's fine. Fair's fair! fair is- woah, fuck I see you.
I thought you already went by, I could have sworn. I know you're there. I see you.
Okay. I see you. Whoa. Okay. All right. Let's not do that.
You're gone... Oh! You're there. Okay, so that's just bizarre.
[Mark sings along to the in-game singing]
BLELELELELE buh dum ba doo
Still there. Okay, a little bit longer. Liiiiittle bit longer.
Yeah, there we go, okay.
So that's just closed now. So all I gotta do is check this side, and I don't even need to check it
I just need to be ready on the door. This is all- this is my life now. 4am, 40 percent. That's pretty good, I'd say
God! Fucking sticky fingers!
Oh, shit. Where did you come from? Fuck?
Got ya!
Ohhh sh it! that- that takes huuuuge hits of power.
Huge hits. That does- that really drains my power, okay. I forgot that Foxy actually hit power down.
Bonnie's there somewhere.
[beep]
God, fuckin sticky fingers! I hate that. Okay, 5am. We're close!...
God, stop being stupid. Where are you Bonnie? Where are you? Oh, you going back? Oh, so you didn't even?
Huh, interesting.
Okay, I'll take that. Alright, powers running out. And...
Okay, come on. Gimme time, gimme time, give it to me, give it to me.
Come on, come on.
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme come on, wait!
[singing] whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa whoa!
Whoa, woah- YES! YES!! YESS!! YESSSSS!!!
Ha HA Ha HA
HA ha HA ha
You suck, I win. Alright.
Hoo, oh boy, here we go.
[singing]
Oh! It's a Bonnie Bite!
Berries and chocolate! I love berries! I love chocolate! And I love BARRY!
So this will be good for me. Mm it was delectible! Doinkus. Okay. Good. Good. Good. Good. Good. Good. Good good
Good
Whew, that was a bit more... trying than I thought, but not as bad as like a twenty mode.
I appreciate the ease of that. x2
I appreciate! the ease of THAT.
So that is all the time I have right now. I gotta get going
We're still filming this amazing project over here, wherever the hell I am. So I got to get back to busiNESS
But thank you, everybody, so much for watching.
Hope you enjoyed that, and I will try to get to more than one of the night fives in the next episode.
It's just I have a limited amount of time right now. So thank you everybody so much, and as always I will see you
in the next video
buh-BYE!
[outro music plays]